[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to the iphone 10 revisited so
the iphone 10 release date was around
six months ago so half a year it's
midway between the cycle and of course
when it first comes out there's a ton of
hype everyone's riding high on that hype
of the newly designed fresh once in a
generation iphone 10. uh even at that
time for a thousand bucks at the end of
my review i did say for people who know
what they're getting into it's probably
worth it now that that hype has died
down though and we've actually used it
and put it through its paces and had our
fair share of issues or non-issues this
is time to revisit if it's worth the
thousand bucks or not so really all the
story is about that design you know
finally a new iphone with a different
design after year after year after year
of the same thing for more than a decade
our intention has been to create an
iphone that is all display
a physical object
that disappears into the experience
[Music]
this is iphone 10.
so really after hearing all this from
apple kind of feels like okay this is
the way things are going to be from now
on you know this is the beginning of the
future of the iphone from here on out
we're going to have these bezel-less
screens we're going to have this top of
the line state-of-the-art tech again
finally in the design department so it's
worth taking a second look at first of
all the name iphone 10. uh everyone
calls it the x so i'd say the name
hasn't held up that well but apple
doesn't really care about that the same
way they didn't care about people
calling it the itouch naming is whatever
it's the iphone 10 but the hardware it
has held up great so this is the second
iphone 10 actually that i've carried
since it came out and i'll get more into
that in a second but every phone wears a
little bit different with different
materials you get different things
happening pixel 2 for example people
thought it might stain after a while in
white it didn't stain but the coating
has worn off and it has this sort of
aging scratching thing going on on the
side so iphone 10 is glass and stainless
steel so it's doing pretty well as
expected the glass accumulates small
scratches over time just like any other
phone that's been normal and the
stainless steel band if you carry it
naked gets tons of you know little micro
scratches no matter how good you take
care of it you're gonna put it in and
out of your pocket all the time it
almost gives it this texture that
gradually looks a little bit different
day after day from when you had a new
phone but still no bend gate or anything
this is definitely a well-built phone
this is iphone 10 but like i said this
is my second iphone 10 and the story of
that i've told this before is
this
i broke it not that i broke it but it
was on the top of a counter and it
buzzed enough times with notifications
to slide to the edge of that counter it
is definitely one of the slipperiest
phones of all time and eventually it
fell off fell about five feet
and cracked and shattered the glass now
you're not supposed to drop basically
any phone from five feet uh but no
matter how durable the glass is like i
said in the review a glass phone is
still a glass phone it's very much more
breakable than things other than glass
so that's just the way it is plus it
doesn't help that it's super slippery i
wouldn't be surprised if this is the
number one most cased phone ever anyway
the one thing we we pretty much know
about apple products is they usually age
pretty well i'd say pretty gracefully
now six months isn't that much it's half
a year so we've gotten a couple ios
updates since it came out i expect many
more for the couple of years to come
apple tends to be pretty good about that
i don't have many concerns that iphone
10 will continue to get those and this
is also now the first iphone to come out
since apple said that they would start
allowing people to choose between clock
speed performance and battery life uh
that's when the phone starts to age so
that'll be interesting to see how it
plays out but really when i say it's
aged gracefully i mean that like as fast
as tech moves now and with the number of
phones that have come out since six
months ago iphone 10 is definitely still
the second or third best smartphone
camera on planet earth it's definitely
one of the most capable as far as power
and will be for a while that a11 bionic
is a beast and aesthetically like i've
said it has held up well now okay we're
six months in and there is no red iphone
10.
uh there's a red iphone 8 and 8 plus and
they are really really red and they look
great but there's no red iphone 10. i am
in the camp that really wishes we had
one uh the best speculation i've heard
as to why we don't is they possibly
couldn't do the band around the outside
the way they wanted to so in the red
iphone 8 not only is the glass back this
vibrant ferrari red but the aluminum
sides of the phone were also matte red
to match but the iphone 10 has stainless
steel sides so the guess is that they
couldn't find the process to make these
stainless steel bands as red as they
wanted to
it's obviously darker on the space gray
iphone and lighter on the silver but red
would have been nice so i don't blame
them for i guess maybe not wanting to do
red back dark band and
actually that kind of would have
that would have looked pretty nice you
know what i take it all back i actually
kind of would have wanted to see a black
side band with the red back apple either
way today we still have the space gray
and the silver uh i actually personally
like the silver to carry more because it
shows less fingerprints apple never
really shows like the sales numbers of
which one sells more i would venture to
guess it's not a big difference so okay
what uh what about the problems that
we've had what about the downsides of
iphone 10 well from the review uh the
holding up the phone to the side and
getting your finger in the corner of the
photo you're taking that stopped real
quick uh tons of phones now have those
cameras in a vertical stack now it's
basically become the standard in the
last couple months so that's no problem
uh lock screen controls that's something
i talked about still can't be changed
but that's an ios thing i didn't expect
a ton of customization to just be added
so that's no surprise it is what it is
just like ios's notifications just like
no headphone jack just like all the
other stubborn little things about the
iphone
that's just the iphone you get used to
it all the gestures i definitely got
used to them they didn't take long to
kind of rely on as they become like my
new default for interacting with an
iphone it feels more natural for a
display that goes right up to the edges
to have swiping gestures from the edges
so it starts off as this really
convoluted complex system but with the
small bezels it actually feels more
correct but then face id face id i've
gotten used to but it is definitely
still my most frustrating part of iphone
10 and i venture to say i'm probably not
alone so it hasn't gotten faster and
with this first gen hardware i don't
really think it's going to get much
faster i think it's about optimized for
what we have so that just means there's
always going to be that split second
delay for unlocking your phone it's not
even that long it's not even half a
second it's a split second
but it's longer than touch id so you
notice it and i still notice it but
what's more annoying is just when my
phone is on a table just on a table in
front of me when it's off axis like this
like most of my day when my phone is on
my desk in front of me having to lean
into the frame for the phone to kind of
see your face is kind of annoying i
think the only way for apple to solve
this would be just by making the array
of dots wider angle or just a little bit
more downward facing for some reason
that's still something i haven't really
adapted to or gotten used to it still
annoys me so it's face id when the phone
is on a table could be better and then
the notch
the glorious
infamous top notch i got used to this
notch pretty quick as i said in the
review it just kind of faded away since
it's not a major part of the ui most of
the time
and as you've seen many others have
added a notch to their phones since then
and many will continue to do so i made a
whole video on the state of bezels in
2018 bezels and notches definitely worth
a click now on iphone 10
it's a big notch like there's no way
around it i don't watch videos full
screen with the notch in there i
actually shrink them down so i don't
miss anything
that's just the way it is now pretty
much every app i use now has been
updated in a way so they just embrace
the notch it's just blank space uh ios
developers have always been pretty damn
responsive so that's awesome but at the
end of the day it is a big notch and i
wish it was smaller but since they are
pushing for this whole bezel-less future
and you do have a really tiny bezel
around the whole rest of the phone i
don't mind it but that actually
naturally brings me to the conclusion
which is what about the next iphone like
we just have a lot of people just bought
this phone which is you know this new
form factor it's got the notch at the
top it's full screen bezel-less
but they just paid a thousand bucks for
it and there's a very low chance that
people spend a thousand bucks two years
a row on a new phone so what's apple
going to do with iphone
11 i guess is what it's probably going
to be called 11. there hasn't really
been a whole lot of leaks about this
next iphone in fact all we really got
was a leaked internal memo
about leaks which is kind of amazing but
really it's inevitable that we get a new
iphone in september and we're wondering
what apple's gonna do with it but as of
right now i'm hoping for two main things
one a bigger screen version and two
a smaller notch i can't stress enough
this notch is huge compared to others in
fact iphone 10 might have right now the
biggest notch of any phone that has one
tons of phones have come out with
smaller and smaller notches i have no
choice but to hope that the sensor
technology improves and we can make a
much smaller notch on iphone 11 and then
i say a bigger screen version like
iphone 10 is about the size of iphone 8.
it would be awesome to have a phone the
size of iphone 8 plus that's also off
screen so we kind of have this sort of a
lineup of a medium and large iphone 11
maybe throw an iphone sc2 in there
somewhere we've had all kinds of rumors
about the way it might line up but at
the end of the day that's what i'm
hoping for is those two main things i
gotta say iphone 10 has held up really
well which is not easy to do the thing
is it's at the top of a really premium
category the 800 900 price point this is
not an impulse buy for most people
getting it but i think the people who
are buying it who know what they're
getting into are willing to accept the
little flaws the little things that are
stubborn about the iphone that aren't
quite all there
and it's been pretty great for the most
part so i think a lot of people are
still satisfied so let me know what you
think have you picked up an iphone 10
are you waiting for iphone 11 or are you
somewhere in between let me know what
your thoughts are until the next one
thanks for watching
talk to the next one peace